well now what I do is I'm a
philanthropic investor and I invest
primarily in early childhood education
and services I spent quite a bit of time
and money on the subject of early
literacy what I did in my business
career I was described as I applied
systems to solutions to large business
problems I was in it that early days of
Federal Express building i was with the
chief information officer back then
after I had left IBM and other private
businesses and I was did that for a
while building the worldwide trading
tracking system then I was chief
operating officer of Federal Express for
about ten years implementing lots of
systems aviation systems computer
systems so I learned a great deal from
that experience that I went and ran a
the largest then the largest sailor
company in the world McCall cellular out
of Seattle we sold that AT&T and became
chief executive officer of AT&T Wireless
back in the early 90s and then I left
that at the behest of some people who
are now great friends of mine to go with
a little startup I figured one more body
to apple so I went down to palo alto in
Mountain View California and became the
chief executive officer of a little
startup called netscape communications
and we taught the world how to use the
internet with the browser and then we
sold that to AOL and 99 and I that's
when I basically retired from active
business went on the Time Warner board
I'm on several boards both public and
private I'm chairman of the board of the
Mayo Clinic out of Rochester Minnesota
and on other private boards are
interested in health care and
human service